it takes a minimum of eight years of
higher education before a student can
call himself or herself a medical doctor
in that time they learn everything about
the human body but what about things non
human what can they teach future MDS and
how does the environment affect human
health in Boston a select group of
Harvard medical students is getting
answers to those questions expanding
their education by taking a trip to the
zoo to get a heart rate on a respirator
on him these are not the patient's
Annabelle an adapt a had in mind when
she first came to Harvard Medical School
see that glottis there but they are the
ones she's caring for in her final weeks
before graduation injecting between the
scale you were taking blood today from
an iguana that can't be taking blood
from a baby that's a completely
different what is the last month been
like for you it has been an incredible
experience just the amount of variety
that I've encountered with the number of
cases that we've seen it's given me sort
of a whole new perspective on the
practice of medicine Anna DAPA is part
of a collaborative program between
Harvard Medical School and the Franklin
Park Zoo called one health it allows med
students to do a veterinary rotation
during their last year of school leaving
the comfort of the classroom for the
wild of the zoo it was such a unique way
to be able to to learn more about about
medicine to apply what I've learned
about human medicine but in a completely
different context some of the most
satisfying cases that I've gotten to
work on have been those that are sort of
common medical illnesses that we deal
with in patients I have seen just a
incredible eagerness and engagement and
every one of our students Franklin Park
Zoo vice president of animal health and
conservation dr. Eric Bateman and
Harvard pathology professor dr. Rick
Mitchell run the program which started
back in 2015 in its simplest terms one
health focuses on the relationship
between people animals and the
environment why do you need to care
about all three all three are
interrelated with each other and
interdependent on each
they're healthy people and animals
depend on a healthy ecosystem and a
healthy ecosystem is a richness of
species and maintenance of biodiversity
and those healthy ecosystems help us to
be healthy as well while comparative
medicine is nothing new Bateman says a
formal program may never have started if
not for one former Harvard Medical
student the beginning of the one health
rotation here was really rather
serendipitous because the that first
student you know emailed me pretty much
out of the blue that student doctor
Gilad ever oniy what was this initial
reaction without even hesitating he said
yes so he was very excited about it I
had already been thinking about how to
build such a program so it was perfect
timing that he would contact me because
Harvard of course is the first place I
thought I was involved with what did you
think when I guess you got a call from
Eric hey why don't you send some Harvard
medical students over here we thought
this is great this sounded like exactly
the sorts of kind of expand mind
expanding experiences that the medical
students would really benefit from
students like ever Oni now an assistant
professor of pediatrics and neuroscience
at NYU though he admits he wasn't
thinking quite so broadly when he first
asked about spending time with the zoo
vets I had no big expectations other
than to just explore my curiosity and
also have a chance to speak to
veterinary doctors and learn from them
right what was amazing is that from the
very first day we could talk about
complex cases with the same language and
that was just the beginning being at the
zoo and spending time there what impact
has that had on you as a doctor I find
myself thinking outside the box more
often than I would have the biggest
impact was in my relationship to
patients especially as a pediatrician
and how I approach my patient this
gentle approach of gradually gaining
trust of your patient that was something
I learned from the veterinarians
from the animals I worked with as for
the newly graduated doctor Annabelle
Anna dapper
so your future as a doctor why are you
better served by knowing about more than
just the human body it's really
important to view the patient-doctor
relationship as within a larger
framework in medical school we learned a
lot about how people's living conditions
their income their occupation will
impact their health one health is sort
of just an additional dimension to that
I think the more that you can maintain
that sort of larger framework and you
approach to patient care and I think
that that serves everyone better all
things
Harvard Medical School alone may not
have been able to teach in the teaching
hospitals at Harvard Medical School they
have every possible test every possible
piece of equipment every consultant that
you could possibly imagine here they
don't the animals can't tell them what's
wrong they actually have to use clinical
intuition and the skills at their
fingertips to kind of figure out what's
going on and I think that's really
valuable is one health creating better
doctors potentially I think it really it
is that this will inform and influence
the way they think about global health
when they are working in their own
community or they're working around the
globe they will think differently about
the health of their patients and put it
in the context the health of the
environment so it's like a micro and a
macro level of everything thirteen
students have gone through the program
they're set going ahead as well and this
as far as we could tell is the only
formal program that is affiliated with a
zoo that a medical school is doing
between Harvard and Boston's Franklin
Park Zoo so interesting like not
everything is in a textbook right right
relying in that or improving the
clinical intuition yeah and I think it
was really important to point out of
course you have tests to do things but
what happens when a patient can't
describe what's going on how do you use
these other senses yeah and how do you
make that connection and they're
learning it because animals can't speak
and can't tell them something like that
a lot of benefits do it yeah Thank You
Dana